[Música]
en senegal los vastos bosques de
casamans cubren una superficie de miles
de hectáreas
la región llamada el pulmón verde del
país es conocida por sus maderas
preciosas como el palo de rosa
La caoba africana y el Peral de cayor
Pero estos últimos años un sistema de
contrabando meticulosamente organizado a
diezmado grandes extensiones del Bosque
[Música]
El follaje aquí antes era tan denso que
ni siquiera podíamos pasar por aquí hoy
en día no hay árboles ni arbustos nada
para alimentar a nuestro ganado
se cree que cada año se Tala una
superficie de árboles tres veces más
grande que París la preciosa madera es
transportada a través de la frontera al
vecino país de gambia
oficialmente senegal ha prohibido la
tala de árboles en este Bosque pero esta
ley está lejos de ser respetada para
contrarrestar esta situación los
activistas medioambientales patrullan
por aquí
el estado es incapaz de supervisar estos
bosques porque la zona es muy extensa y
ahí donde el estado falla estamos
nosotros para hacernos cargo
hoy el último grupo descubre un
campamento clandestino
Esto está recién cortado
por aquí pasaron hombres con motosierras
hace poco un poco más lejos
se oyen motosierras los leñadores están
allí a unos 100 metros
decidimos mantener la distancia
están mejor armadas que el mismo
ejército tienen ak-47 es un medio de
vida harán cualquier cosa para
defenderse la mercancía se exporta china
en un barco para ser transformada en
muebles de lujo y hay que decir que es
un negocio lucrativo
las exportaciones de palo de rosa de
gambia ascienden a 200 millones de euros
en 6 años dinero que llega
principalmente a un grupo armado
independentista
desde principios de año los
enfrentamientos entre las autoridades
locales y los leñadores clandestinos han
dejado seis muertos
eso no es suficiente para disuadir a
este contrabandista quien desea guardar
su anonimato sabemos que estamos matando
el Bosque pero no tenemos trabajo Esto
es lo único que podemos hacer para
sobrevivir
El problema es que entrar a gambia es
muy fácil la frontera está marcada con
piedras en el suelo y prácticamente no
está vigilada
aquí se ve la madera cortada ilegalmente
a 100 metros de la frontera con senegal
al menos 12 depósitos de madera como
este han sido encontrados en gambia
justo al otro lado de la frontera
el país logra lasaña de ser uno de los
cinco mayores exportadores del palo de
rosa a pesar de tener muy pocos bosques
todo el mundo ve entrar la madera pero
nadie hace nada eso nos rompe el corazón
hay una mafia de la madera en senegal
también hay corrupción a la gente que se
supone que debe supervisar esta zona se
le paga para que deje entrar la madera
la corrupción es la mayor parte del
problema las autoridades senegalesas
dicen que no es así culpan a los
residentes locales que según dicen
ayudan a los traficantes
necesitamos que la población local nos
ayude a Identificar y rastrear a esos
traficantes
cada año se exportan unas 100 mil
toneladas de palo de rosa desde gambia y
la destrucción de los últimos bosques de
senegal no disminuye
[Música]